-Avant, mon invitée était plutôt
du genre à porter
une tenue de radioprotection
avec un compteur Geiger à la main.
Depuis qu'elle s'est lancée
en politique,
on l'envoie en première ligne
quand il faut éteindre un incendie.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Maud Bregeon.
-Bonjour.
-Je le disais,
avant la politique, vous occupiez
un poste un peu particulier
chez EDF.
Vous êtes intervenue,
notamment,
en situation de crise
à Saint-Martin,
après le passage d'Irma,
pour rétablir le courant.
C'était pas l'essentiel
de votre travail,
chez EDF.
-Non. L'essentiel de la mission,
mon premier poste,
c'est comment vous faites,
en cas d'accident grave,
une tempête,
un ouragan,
un tremblement de terre,
pour réalimenter
la centrale en eau,
en air et en électricité ?
Et donc, faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de fonte du coeur,
tout simplement.
-Du coeur d'une centrale nucléaire.
Vous parlez
de catastrophe nucléaire.
-C'était une unité d'intervention
créée après Fukushima.
Après Fukushima,
on a réalisé
que les moyens disponibles
sur la centrale en cas d'accident,
il ne fallait pas nécessairement
compter dessus
et pouvoir en amener de l'extérieur.
-Vous deviez monter
une cellule de crise tout près ?
-Comment vous montez
un poste de commandement,
faites venir
des équipes externes.
Comment vous acheminez du matériel ?
Comment est-ce que vous réalimentez
en carburant ?
Comment est-ce que vous maintenez
à bonne pression le réacteur ?
Comment vous remettez
de l'eau dedans,
pour le refroidir ?
-Il faut aimer
le risque pour ce métier ?
-Il faut aimer le risque,
la découverte.
Moi, c'était une découverte.
Le nucléaire,
je ne le connaissais pas.
Il faut aimer le contact humain.
C'est un vrai travail
d'équipe, la gestion de crise,
avec les techniciens,
avec les préfectures,
les pouvoirs publics.
Moi, j'ai beaucoup appris,
parce qu'il y a à la fois
des compétences techniques,
sur comment fonctionne
une centrale, comment fonctionnent
les matériels
dont vous avez besoin,
et puis, comment vous intervenez
en gestion de crise.
Vous êtes pas dans du management,
vous êtes
dans du commandement.
D'ailleurs,
on travaillait avec les armées,
qui nous ont aidés.
Ils ont l'habitude d'interventions
en situation déstructurée.
-Vous avez fait
des études d'ingénieur,
mais c'est pas ce que
vous vouliez faire.
Vous étiez plutôt attirée
par les sciences politiques.
Pourquoi y renoncer ?
-Je suis issue d'une famille
où on a toujours beaucoup parlé
politique.
Mes parents n'en faisaient pas,
mais s'y intéressaient.
C'était très présent à table.
J'ai eu, effectivement, envie
de faire des sciences politiques.
Quand on est au lycée,
on pense à Sciences Po.
Je suis d'une famille où,
aussi, on m'a toujours dit
que l'important,
c'était la sécurité de l'emploi.
Je viens d'une famille modeste.
Mon papa a connu des périodes
de chômage dans sa vie.
-C'est pour être sûr d'avoir un job
qu'il vous a dit de faire
des études d'ingénieur ?
-Issu du monde ouvrier, il m'a dit :
"Ingénieur,
c'est la sécurité de l'emploi."
Au fond, pour moi,
qui étais bonne en maths,
c'était à la fois la maîtrise
du risque et la garantie
d'un avenir stable.
-Ca ne vous a pas empêchée
de garder un oeil sur la politique
longtemps,
avec une orientation à droite,
mais votre premier engagement,
c'est en 2017,
comme militante
pour Emmanuel Macron
dans sa campagne présidentielle.
Vous êtes devenue référente
En Marche
dans les Hauts-de-Seine,
tête de liste aux municipales
à Levallois. Vous n'avez pas cherché
à chasser le naturel,
cette attirance vers la politique ?
Elle n'est pas revenue au galop
dans votre vie ?
-Je ne dirais pas
que j'ai cherché à la chasser,
parce que...
Durant ma prépa à Paris,
je regardais,
- c'est pas une blague -
LCP, je me rappelle très bien,
sur mon petit poste de télé,
cathodique, à l'époque,
et effectivement, c'est revenu.
C'est revenu, parce que...
C'était une période où j'étais
installée professionnellement.
J'avais du temps.
Et parce que... Emmanuel Macron.
-Vous avez été comme happée
par la politique, comme si ça venait
répondre à un besoin qui était pas
tout à fait comblé,
peut-être par votre job
d'avant ?
-C'est un besoin d'engagement.
Il y a un lien entre le travail
qui était le mien chez EDF
et le mien en politique :
la notion de service public.
C'est la notion de service
à l'autre.
EDF, le service public
de l'électricité,
c'est les hommes en bleu
venus vous réalimenter
le soir de la tempête de 99,
qui montent aux poteaux
et font que vous avez
de l'électricité.
-Le besoin d'avoir du sens
dans votre action quotidienne.
-Peut-être que le petit dénominateur
commun entre les deux,
c'est que ce sont des missions
dans lesquelles
on donne pour les autres
et où l'intérêt général a sa place.
-Autre date
dans votre engagement politique :
octobre 2020.
C'est une nouvelle étape.
La République En Marche décide
de nommer deux femmes,
venues de la société civile,
pour occuper des fonctions
de porte-parole.
Vous tentez votre chance
parmi de nombreuses candidates.
Et le résultat, ça donne ça.
*-Maud Bregeon. J'ai 29 ans.
Ingénieur de l'énergie,
spécialisée en gestion de crise.
Musique dynamique
Parce que c'était un processus
qui a été transparent,
avec des règles,
claires et connues de tous,
parce que ça montre
qu'on est un mouvement
qui s'ouvre à la société civile.
On est un mouvement qui prône
la parité et qui l'applique.
-Vous l'évoquez brièvement,
dans cette vidéo,
mais vous avez franchi
les étapes d'un casting,
digne de la "Star Ac'",
sauf que là,
c'était pour être porte-parole.
-De la "Star Ac'", peut-être pas !
-Il y a plusieurs jurys,
qui ont sélectionné
et écrémé, petit à petit.
-Oui, non, mais...
il y a eu une vidéo, qu'on a dû
envoyer pour se présenter,
montrer comment on parlait
devant une caméra
et ensuite,
plusieurs étapes de sélection.
-Comme une vraie... ?
-Comme sur un plateau,
avec des journalistes
qui posent des questions,
format "Grand jury" et donc,
il y a eu plusieurs étapes
successives, et c'est comme ça
que j'ai été recrutée.
Ce qui est extrêmement important,
dans cette étape,
c'est que La République En Marche,
qui n'a pas tout réussi,
démontre quelque chose d'important :
elle a eu cette volonté,
jusqu'au bout, de faire monter
des jeunes de la société civile,
qui n'avaient pas fait de politique.
Je me rappelle une amie,
Aurélie Taquillain,
élue à Courbevoie, de chez LR,
m'avait dit :
"Nous, chez LR,
"on prenait notre ticket
et on attendait 25 ans."
-C'est vrai que là,
vous avez été propulsée
dans des fonctions
de porte-parole...
-Le macronisme a réussi
à mettre sur le devant de la scène
des gens qui, dans la logique
de l'ancien monde,
n'auraient pas dû y être.
-Longtemps,
vous avez été porte-parole du parti
de la majorité présidentielle,
en restant salariée d'EDF.
Vous avez mené une double vie.
Le soir, vous deviez aller
sur les plateaux télé,
pour défendre l'action
de la majorité. Vous avez
survécu à ça ?
-Au prix d'une bonne partie
de ma vie personnelle, déjà.
-Vous n'aviez plus de temps
pour vous.
-Porte-parole,
c'est une mission bénévole.
Il faut bien continuer
à payer le loyer et les factures.
Ce qui est difficile, au fond,
c'est la gymnastique mentale
que ça demande.
La journée, vous vous occupez
des centrales,
de la production d'électricité.
Entre midi et deux,
vous allez parler du Covid
sur BFM TV,
et puis, vous revenez
à votre travail,
et le soir, vous reparlez
d'immigration et de sécurité.
La clé, c'est le travail.
Quand j'ai été nommée,
on m'a donné plusieurs conseils.
Darmanin m'a dit :
"Prends un ou deux dossiers
et tu les travailles à fond."
Et le deuxième conseil
qu'on m'a donné, c'est :
"Continue de parler
comme les gens.
"Sois qui tu es,
communique simplement."
Je pense que l'authenticité,
c'est important.
Venir de la société civile,
peut-être que ça le permet,
en partie.
Pas uniquement.
Les gens qui ont fait
que de la politique
le sont aussi parfois.
-Ma question,
vous y avez presque répondu :
on vous a donné des conseils
avant de vous envoyer
sur les plateaux des chaînes info,
face à des adversaires aguerris,
des journalistes
qui cherchent la petite bête ?
-Oui, il y avait une équipe
derrière qui nous a entraînées
à la communication aux médias,
pour commencer quelques heures.
On apprend beaucoup sur le tas.
Comment on est
sur un plateau ?
La façon dont on s'exprime,
ça tient beaucoup de qui on est.
Et puis, ensuite, encore une fois,
ça tient sur le travail qu'on abat.
On ne va pas en plateau
sans ferrailler
les dossiers.
On ne parle pas de sujets
sans connaître les chiffres
sans avoir mûri notre réflexion.
L'objectif, c'est de pas être
des machines à faire
des Ctrl C Ctrl V
d'éléments de langage.
Pour ça, ça nécessite d'avoir
une réflexion personnelle
sur les choses.
C'est toujours ce que
j'ai essayé de faire :
d'avoir cette approche
qui est mienne,
qui tient à mon vécu.
Je crois que les gens,
ils cherchent la sincérité.
Ils sont pas forcément d'accord.
L'important, c'est d'être sincère.
Ca se voit.
-Quelques semaines
après la nomination,
vous êtes face à Florian Philippot
sur le plateau de CNews.
Je vous vois rire.
Vous avez sorti
une série de punchlines,
comme on dit,
ça a fait le tour du Web.
Je crois que le petit extrait
que vous avez posté
en est à 1,8 million de vues
sur Twitter.
On le regarde.
*-M. Philippot, vous voulez
qu'on parle de résultats ?
La dernière fois
que vous vous êtes présenté,
aux européennes,
vous avez fait 0,65 %,
moins que le Parti Animaliste.
-Ne les méprisez pas.
J'ai eu le mérite d'y aller.
Vous avez fait quoi ?
-Tête de liste à Levallois-Perret.
-Vous avez fait quoi ?
-J'ai fait 15 % au 1er tour.
Au 2e, on a fait 33.
-Dans votre vie,
vous avez fait quoi ?
-Je suis ingénieur
dans le nucléaire.
J'ai un métier. Je ne fais pas
que de la politique.
-Dans votre vie...
-Enarque antisystème !
Extraordinaire !
-Je suis fils d'instituteurs.
-Vous les aviez préparées,
ces formules ?
Elles sont sorties comme ça ?
-La toute première,
j'y avais pensé avant,
le score aux européennes.
Le reste, non. Ca vient
naturellement, du fait de l'échange.
Je ne sais pas
si je le referais aujourd'hui.
-Ah bon ?
-Il fallait quand même avoir
un certain aplomb...
-Oui ! En même temps,
vous parlez de rester soi-même.
Vous ne le referiez pas ?
Vous êtes formatée, maintenant ?
-On se formate un peu,
avec le temps. Il faut essayer
de lutter contre ça.
Non, mais il y a une sacrée dose
de provocation.
J'essaye, peut-être,
aujourd'hui,
d'être un peu moins...
Voilà, d'être... un peu moins
dans la provocation, mais peut-être
que l'époque est comme ça aussi.
On est dans une période
politique et sociétale
qui est compliquée.
Donc,
j'essaye davantage aujourd'hui
d'adoucir les choses.
-D'arrondir les angles.
-Et d'essayer, voilà,
de rechercher un consensus
plutôt que des provocations.
-On parlait du risque à propos
de votre 1er métier chez EDF.
On le retrouve dans la fonction
de porte-parole,
quand on est face
à des adversaires
sans trop savoir où on va aller ?
-Ca tient aussi
de son caractère.
J'ai toujours été bagarreuse,
j'ai toujours eu un franc-parler,
je me suis toujours... J'ai toujours
été amenée à m'exprimer.
Quand j'étais petite,
mes parents me demandaient mon avis.
J'étais écoutée.
Ca vient aussi de l'éducation.
-C'est l'heure
de notre quiz spécial
porte-parole.
Trois petites questions,
trois réponses rapides.
On commence.
Quel journaliste
redoutez-vous le plus ?
-Euh...
-Ca ne vient pas ?
-Ca vient pas naturellement.
-Peur de personne ?
-J'ai pas peur de personne,
mais ça dépend des contextes.
J'ai fait Apolline de Malherbe
en début de semaine.
-Elle est coriace.
-Elle est coriace, oui.
-Quel adversaire politique
est le plus coriace ?
-Je sais pas. Ca dépend
des moments.
-Il faut une réponse !
La porte-parole...
-Avec la Nupes
et le RN, au fond,
on a des divergences flagrantes,
tellement visibles,
que... le téléspectateur,
à mon avis,
se fait facilement une opinion
sur ce qu'on dit.
-Pour 2027, vous êtes plutôt
Bruno Le Maire, Gérald Darmanin,
ou Edouard Philippe ?
Pas de langue de bois !
-Emmanuel Macron !
-Impossible.
Vous le savez.
Langue de bois.
-Ca n'a pas de sens,
de répondre à ça maintenant.
Ca n'a pas de sens.
On est en train de faire passer
une réforme des retraites, je...
Je fais de la politique
depuis peu.
Je sais pas
si j'en ferai en 2027.
Honnêtement, j'en sais rien.
-On suivra ça.
-Oui !
-Merci beaucoup, Maud Bregeon,
d'être venue.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...